Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
SO, WE'VE DONE $3 MILLION
TO DATE.
WOW.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY,
ASTRONOMICALLY MASSIVE.
ABSOLUTELY,
ASTRONOMICALLY MASSIVE?
YES! YES!
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
WE SOLD $10,000 WORTH OF PRODUCT
THE FIRST DAY.
THAT'S AWESOME.
Narrator: ...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
YOU CAN ACTUALLY FIND GOLD
IN THE HOME DEPOT SAND.
GOLD!
Narrator: ...AND FIGHT
EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PARTICIPATE
IN ONE OF THOSE,
OR ARE YOU STUPID
AND GONNA PAY MORE THAN THAT?
OHH!
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
WE THINK WE'LL LOSE MONEY AGAIN
NEXT YEAR.
UH-OH.
I WOULD LOVE TO COUNTER
YOUR OFFER.
YOU'RE JOKING.
YOU'D HAVE TO GIVE ME
HALF THE COMPANY.
THAT WOULD BE COMPLETELY ABSURD.
I'M SORRY.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT
FROM WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
I'M LIZ.
AND I'M BEN.
AND WE'RE
FROM PORTLAND, OREGON.
AND WE MET AND STARTED DATING
IN COLLEGE.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN PASSIONATE
ABOUT WOMEN'S ISSUES,
SPECIFICALLY THE CHALLENGES
FACING WOMEN
LIVING IN
DEVELOPING ECONOMIES.
SO, AFTER UNIVERSITY,
I TOOK A HUGE LEAP OF FAITH
AND MOVED TO UGANDA.
THE GREATEST NEED FOR WOMEN
IN UGANDA
IS EDUCATIONAL
AND ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES.
SO, I DECIDED
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
LIZ ISN'T AFRAID
TO TAKE RISKS.
SHE DOES THINGS
THAT MOST PEOPLE WOULDN'T DO,
AND I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
SO IMPRESSED BY THAT.
I DECIDED TO QUIT MY JOB
AS A CONSULTANT,
AND TOGETHER,
WE'VE BUILT SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE
SUPER PROUD OF.
HEY, AGNES.
GOOD MORNING.
Hi, Liz and Ben.
OUR GENERATION IS LESS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE BIG BRAND NAME
AND MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACT
THAT THEIR PRODUCTS HAVE
ON THE WORLD.
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO A GREAT YEAR.
WHEN WE STARTED THE COMPANY,
WE DECIDED WHOLEHEARTEDLY
THAT WE WANTED TO BE
A FOR-PROFIT COMPANY.
WE BELIEVE THAT CREATING
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
CAN HAVE A MORE LASTING IMPACT
THAN SOME CHARITIES.
I THINK THAT'S
REALLY OUR SWEET SPOT.
WE HAVE SPENT
THE LAST FIVE YEARS
DOING
THE REALLY HARD WORK.
AND NOW WE JUST NEED TO MAKE
A NAME FOR OURSELVES IN AMERICA.
WE BELIEVE THAT
IF EVERY WOMAN IN AMERICA
KNEW ABOUT OUR COMPANY,
WE COULD MAKE A MASSIVE IMPACT
FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS
ALL ACROSS THE GLOBE.
HI, SHARKS.
WE'RE LIZ AND BEN BOHANNON.
WE'RE
FROM PORTLAND, OREGON,
AND WE'RE THE HUSBAND-AND-WIFE
TEAM BEHIND SSEKO DESIGNS.
WE'RE SEEKING $300,000
FOR 10% EQUITY IN OUR COMPANY.
WITH SSEKO, ONE SANDAL HAS
ENDLESS POSSIBILITIES.
OUR FIRST PRODUCT IS
THE SSEKO RIBBON SANDAL,
A BOHO-CHIC, HAND-CRAFTED,
LEATHER SANDAL
WITH INTERCHANGEABLE
STRAPS
THAT CAN BE TIED AND STYLED
IN HUNDREDS OF WAYS.
FROM A FUNKY CRISSCROSS
TO A CLASSIC FLIP-FLOP,
THIS SANDAL ALLOWS HER
TO CHANGE HER LOOK
DAY TO DAY
AND SEASON TO SEASON.
AND OUR SOPHISTICATED
LEATHER T-STRAP SANDAL
FEATURES
INTERCHANGEABLE ACCENTS
THAT COMPLETELY CHANGE THE LOOK
OF THIS SANDAL
WITH ONE SIMPLE STEP,
MAKING SSEKOS
THE PERFECT SANDALS
FOR JET-SETTERS
AND TRENDSETTERS ALIKE.
SIMPLY CHOSE
YOUR SANDAL BASE,
PICK YOUR STRAPS AND ACCENTS,
AND STYLE YOUR SSEKOS.
BUT WHAT MAKES THIS
CUSTOMIZABLE, VERSATILE SANDAL
EVEN BETTER IS THAT EVERY
SANDAL, STRAP, AND ACCESSORY
YOU PURCHASE
DIRECTLY HELPS
TO EMPOWER AND EDUCATE A WOMAN
IN EAST AFRICA.
YOU SEE, WE'VE DEVELOPED
AN INNOVATIVE WORK-STUDY PROGRAM
THAT EMPLOYS BRIGHT,
PASSIONATE YOUNG WOMEN
WHO COME FROM BACKGROUNDS
OF POVERTY TO MAKE THE SANDALS,
TO EARN MONEY, TO GO TO COLLEGE,
AND PURSUE THEIR DREAMS.
NOW, DON'T JUST
TAKE IT FROM US.
HERE'S A MESSAGE
FROM OUR TEAM IN UGANDA.
SSEKO DESIGNS IS USING FASHION
TO EDUCATE AND EMPOWER WOMEN.
NOW, WHICH SHARK WANTS TO BE
A PART OF THE NEXT CHAPTER
OF THE SSEKO STORY?
Together:
EVERY SANDAL HAS A STORY!
[ WOMEN CHEERING ]
THAT WAS GREAT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
NOW, WHICH ONE
OF YOU SHARKS
WANTS TO BE A PART OF BUILDING
A POWERFUL, GLOBAL BRAND
THAT WILL BE KNOWN
FOR MAKING
BEAUTIFUL PRODUCTS
WITH BEAUTIFUL STORIES?
ARE YOU INTO THIS
FOR PROFIT?
YES, WE ARE ABSOLUTELY,
100% A FOR-PROFIT COMPANY.
SO, YOU DONATE WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF YOUR REVENUE TO THIS --
SO, WE DO NOT DONATE
ANYTHING.
ALL OF OUR KIND OF
"PHILANTHROPY"
COMES FROM
OUR PRODUCTION SIDE.
YOU'RE MAKING THE SANDALS
IN UGANDA --
THEY MAKE IT.
SO, LITERALLY, INSTEAD OF
MAKING THEM OFFSHORE IN CHINA,
WE'VE SAID, "LET'S BE
REALLY INTENTIONAL
ABOUT WHERE WE MAKE
THE PRODUCT."
WE BELIEVE PASSIONATELY THAT
BUSINESS HAS A POWERFUL ROLE
IN MAKING THE WORLD
A BETTER PLACE,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE DOING.
LOVE IT,
BUT IS IT CHEAPER THAN CHINA?
IT IS COMPARABLE
TO CHINA.
WALK US --
CAN WE SEE IT?
YEAH. YEAH.
LET'S -- LET'S TRY SOME --
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
LET'S DEFINITELY --
SO, THESE ARE THE ONLY TWO
SANDAL MODELS THAT WE DO HAVE.
WE ARE EXPANDING INTO
CLOSED-TOED SHOES, AS WELL,
BUT THE SANDALS ARE DEFINITELY
OUR MAIN PRODUCT,
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
BEEN SELLING TO DATE.
Herjavec:
THEY'RE ONLY FOR WOMEN.
HOW COMFORTABLE IS THAT
TO WEAR?
THEY'RE VERY COMFORTABLE.
IT'S A
GENUINE-LEATHER BASE,
REAL LEATHER SOURCED
FROM KENYA.
IT HAS A LAYER OF MICRO FOAM
IN THE MIDDLE,
SO IT REALLY FORMS
TO YOUR FOOT
AFTER YOU GET DONE
WEARING IT.
I WEAR THEM ALL DAY,
EVERY DAY.
WE'VE HAD WOMEN
THAT HAVE TREKKED
THROUGH THE AMAZON
IN THEM.
SERIOUSLY? [ LAUGHS ]
WHAT DO YOU SELL
THE SANDALS FOR?
WE SELL ABOUT TWO PAIRS
OF RIBBONS WITH EACH BASE.
SO, THAT'S GONNA RETAIL
FOR RIGHT AROUND $65,
AND THE COST ON THAT --
$65 FOR THIS,
A FLIP-FLOP?
YES.
HOW DID YOU GET INVOLVED
WITH UGANDA?
I MEAN, IT'S NOT A TYPICAL THING
SOMEONE WOULD DO.
SO, I WENT TO UNIVERSITY.
I STUDIED JOURNALISM.
I WAS SUPER PASSIONATE
ABOUT WOMEN'S ISSUES,
AND SO GOT OUT OF COLLEGE,
GOT MY FIRST CORPORATE JOB.
THAT LASTED
FOR ABOUT TWO MONTHS.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WHILE I WAS SITTING
AT MY CUBICLE,
I BOUGHT A ONE-WAY TICKET
TO EAST AFRICA
AND DECIDED THAT I WAS GONNA
GO JUST BE ON THE GROUND
AND LEARN ABOUT THE ISSUES
THAT WOMEN AND GIRLS FACE THERE.
AND WHY SHOES?
YOU JUST WOKE UP ONE DAY AND
SAID, "LET'S DO A SHOE COMPANY"?
NO, SO,
WHAT HAPPENED WAS
I WAS WORKING AT A
YOUTH-DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATION,
MET AN INCREDIBLE GROUP
OF YOUNG WOMEN BASICALLY MY AGE,
BACKGROUNDS
OF EXTREME POVERTY,
AND THEY WERE GETTING READY
TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL,
AND THEY WERE GONNA
GO BACK TO THEIR VILLAGES
FOR THIS
NINE-MONTH BREAK.
IT'S INTENDED
TO ALLOW STUDENTS
THAT ACTUALLY TEST INTO COLLEGE
TO FIND TIME TO FIND A JOB
SO THAT THEY CAN PAY
FOR COLLEGE.
SO, YOU HAVE TO PAY UP FRONT,
OR YOU'RE NOT GOING.
BASICALLY, WHAT WAS HAPPENING
WITH THESE YOUNG WOMEN --
THEY WERE GRADUATING FROM
THIS SECONDARY-SCHOOL PROGRAM,
TESTING INTO COLLEGE,
HAD ALL OF THIS GUSTO AND VISION
FOR WHO THEY WANTED TO BECOME
AND WHAT THEY WANTED TO DO,
WERE GOING BACK TO THEIR
VILLAGES, COULDN'T FIND JOBS.
AND SO I THOUGHT,
"MAN, WHAT IF
WE COULD ACTUALLY BUILD
A MARKETPLACE SOLUTION?"
ONE OF MY FRIENDS WAS LIKE,
"WHAT ABOUT THOSE, LIKE, FUNKY,
STRAPPY SANDALS YOU WORE IN
COLLEGE THAT EVERYBODY LOVED?"
I HAD MADE THESE SANDALS
IN COLLEGE OUT OF, LITERALLY,
FLIP-FLOP BOTTOMS
AND RIBBON.
AND IT WAS ONE OF
THOSE THINGS WHERE,
WHEN I WOULD WEAR IT,
PEOPLE WOULD LITERALLY
STOP ME ON THE STREET
AND ASK ME ABOUT THEM.
AND SO I WAS LIKE,
"OKAY, SURE, SANDALS."
[ LAUGHS ]
AND THEN I WENT TO THE SCHOOL
AND HIRED THREE WOMEN --
MARY, MERCY,
AND REBECCA --
AND TAUGHT THEM
HOW TO MAKE THE SANDALS
AND BASICALLY SAID,
"OKAY, IF YOU PROMISE
"TO MAKE THESE SANDALS
FOR THE NEXT NINE MONTHS,
I PROMISE THAT YOU WILL GO
TO COLLEGE IN THE FALL."
LIZ, HOW MUCH MONEY
DID THOSE THREE LADIES NEED
TO GET TO COLLEGE?
COLLEGE IS ABOUT $2,000
TO $3,000 A YEAR, SO --
SO, YOU GUARANTEED THEM
THE $2,000 TO $3,000
BEFORE YOU HAD ANY SALES.
YEAH. YEAH.
I LOVE THAT.
YEAH, SO, THAT'S WHEN --
WHEN I GOT HOME,
ABOUT TWO DAYS LATER,
BEN PROPOSED TO ME,
AND I'M THINKING,
"DO I TELL HIM
"THAT I PROMISED THREE WOMEN
IN AFRICA
I'D PAY FOR THEM
TO GO TO UNIVERSITY?"
HOW MANY WOMEN
ARE THERE NOW?
SO, WE'VE HAD 47 WOMEN WHO HAVE
GONE THROUGH OUR PROGRAM.
WOW.
Herjavec: WOW.
100% OF THE WOMEN
WHO HAVE GRADUATED FROM SSEKO
HAVE GONE ON
TO UNIVERSITY
AND HAVE EITHER GRADUATED
FROM COLLEGE
OR ARE STILL PURSUING
THEIR DEGREES.
GOOD FOR YOU. THAT'S AWESOME.
YOU'RE IN RETAIL. DO YOU HAVE
SALES? WHERE ARE YOU?
Ben: SO, WE'VE DONE $3 MILLION
TO DATE.
THIS YEAR, WE'LL DO
$1.1 MILLION.
AND WHAT WILL YOU MAKE
ON THAT $1.1 MILLION?
2009, '10, '11, AND '12,
WE WERE PROFITABLE.
OKAY, BUT THIS YEAR?
SO, ONCE WE HIT A POINT
IN UGANDA WHERE WE SAID,
"HEY, WE CAN SCALE THIS"...
OH, NICE, LORI.
..."LET'S GO,
LET'S GROW IT,
"LET'S GET INTO
MAJOR DISTRIBUTION,
LET'S GET INTO
MAJOR RETAILERS," WE --
IN 2012,
WE OPENED A DEBT ROUND.
WE DID $250,000 IN DEBT
SO THAT WE COULD GO OUT
AND HIRE OUR FIRST SALESPEOPLE.
AND HOW MUCH MONEY
ARE YOU MAKING NOW?
WE'LL RUN A LOSS THIS YEAR
OF RIGHT AROUND $90,000.
WHAT ABOUT NEXT YEAR?
NEXT YEAR, THE GOAL IS
TO DO $1.9 MILLION.
AND WHAT ARE YOU GONNA MAKE
ON THAT?
WE THINK WE'LL LOSE MONEY AGAIN
NEXT YEAR.
WHY ARE YOU LOSING SO MUCH MONEY
ON $1.9 MILLION?
WHY ARE YOU LOSING MONEY
YEAH. SO, THE --
I MEAN, THE BIGGEST THING --
WE'RE ADD-- WE'RE STILL GONNA
CONTINUE TO ADD SALESPEOPLE.
CAN YOU TELL ME
HOW MUCH SALARY YOU'RE TAKING?
WE'RE RIGHT AROUND $45,000
AS A PACKAGE DEAL RIGHT NOW.
COMBINED?
TOTAL?
YEAH.
SO, HOW DO I GET
TO $3 MILLION...
YEAH.
...FOR SSEKO?
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
SO, WE THINK IT'S --
IT'S VERY FAIR TO LOOK AT --
WE'RE EVEN LOOKING
AT LAST YEAR'S NUMBERS --
SO, TAKING
LIKE A $2.7 MULTIPLE
ON OUR REVENUE
FROM LAST YEAR.
YOU WANT TO VALUE IT ON REVENUE
AND NOT PROFIT?
AND THAT'S A --
THAT'S A NORMAL THING,
TO VALUE SOMETHING
ON REVENUE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE A BRAND.
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE BRAND SPACE
OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING --
BUT YOU'RE NOT A BRAND. I'VE
NEVER HEARD OF YOU TILL NOW.
WELL, YOU WILL.
LAST YEAR ON "SHARK TANK,"
WE HAD A MOST ENDEARING COUPLE
HERE WHO OWNED A BUSINESS
NAMED GRACE AND LACE.
THEY MAKE THESE ADORABLE LITTLE
LACE LINERS FOR YOUR BOOTS.
Ben: MM-HMM.
IT'S AN
INTERESTING PARALLEL.
THEIR PHILOSOPHY WAS
THEY BELIEVED IN HELPING PEOPLE,
AND THEIR INTENTION WAS TO TAKE
WHATEVER PROFITS THEY HAD
AND SPEND HALF OF THAT PROFIT
IMMEDIATELY ON HELPING PEOPLE.
THEY SOLD
$1 MILLION WORTH OF SOCKS
WITHIN A WEEK
OF "SHARK TANK."
IT'S EXACTLY ONE YEAR LATER,
AND THEY WILL HAVE
$10 MILLION IN SALES.
THAT'S AWESOME.
BUT HERE'S THE DIFFERENCE
THAT DISTURBS ME --
THEY WERE HYPER-FOCUSED
ON PROFIT FIRST.
THEY WERE FOCUSED
ON CHARITY SECOND.
NOW THEY, FORTUNATELY, HAVE
BUILT THREE ORPHANAGES IN INDIA.
YEAH. YEAH.
BUT I WAS ABLE TO MAKE $400,000
ON $40,000.
YEAH. WITH --
I'M A HAPPY INVESTOR.
YEAH, YOU SHOULD BE.
IT'S VERY HARD TO BUY
INTO SOMEONE'S PHILOSOPHY
IF THERE ARE PROJECTED LOSSES
WITHOUT CLARITY AS TO HOW
YOU'RE GONNA GET TO PROFIT.
I WAS HOPING YOU WERE
MY NEXT GRACE AND LACE.
YEAH.
BUT I'M SORRY TO SAY
I'M OUT.
THANKS, BARBARA.
HERE'S WHAT
I WILL SAY --
WE ARE MORE DRIVEN
TO MAKE MONEY
AND TO MAKE
THIS BUSINESS WORK
THAN WE WOULD BE
IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT.
GUYS, LOOK, I DON'T QUESTION
YOUR PROFIT MOTIVATION.
IT'S THERE.
IT'S OBVIOUS.
WHAT I LOOK FOR
ARE CERTAIN KEYWORDS
THAT TELL ME
HOW REALISTIC YOU ARE,
BECAUSE,
AS ENTREPRENEURS,
YOU'RE NOT ALWAYS REALISTIC,
RIGHT?
YEP.
YOU LIE TO YOURSELF.
YOU GET ALL EXCITED.
YOU GET ALL FIRED UP.
YEAH.
BUT AT SOME POINT,
YOU HAVE TO BE REALISTIC
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO PAY
THE BILLS, RIGHT?
YEAH, WE WERE
TOP-5 SOCIAL ENTERPRISES
BY BLOOMBERG MAGAZINE.
I MEAN,
WE'RE A SOCIAL INNOVATION.
WE WERE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE, LIKE --
YOU'RE -- YOU'RE ACTUALLY
MAKING MY POINT.
ALL THE DIFFERENT THINGS YOU'VE
BEEN RECOGNIZED FOR, RIGHT?
YEP.
ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU'VE HIRED TO SELL,
AND THAT'S ONLY GOTTEN YOU
TO $1.1 MILLION IN SALES.
YEP.
RIGHT?
I JUST DON'T SEE
THE CAUSE AND EFFECT,
AND I SEE A LOT
OF SELF-PROMOTION
THAT DOESN'T GET ME
FROM HERE
TO WHERE I THINK
YOU GUYS WANT TO GO.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANKS, MAN.
YOU KNOW, YOU ARE NOT WORTH
$3 MILLION BY ANY MEASURE.
I'M SORRY.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
SHOE COMPANIES AROUND THE WORLD.
THEY ALL TRADE PRETTY WELL
IN THE SAME RANGE,
LOTS OF COMPETITION.
I THINK YOU'RE WORTH SOMEWHERE
AROUND $700,000, ALL-IN.
YOU'D HAVE TO GIVE ME
HALF THE COMPANY.
UH-OH.
Narrator: TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
LIZ AND BEN ONLY HAVE THREE MORE
CHANCES TO MAKE A DEAL
FOR THEIR INTERCHANGEABLE SANDAL
COMPANY, SSEKO.
I THINK YOU'RE WORTH SOMEWHERE
AROUND $700,000, ALL-IN.
YOU'D HAVE TO GIVE ME
HALF THE COMPANY.
WE'RE NEVER GONNA GET TO A DEAL,
SO I'M OUT.
WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT EXPERTISE HERE.
I'M REALLY GOOD
AT TAKING A SMALL COMPANY
AND MAKING IT BIG
IN A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME.
WHEN YOU'RE THIS SMALL,
YOU WANT TO INVEST
AFTER THE SALES COME IN.
TO SUPPORT THE SALES,
NOT INVEST AHEAD
OF THE SALES.
YOU'RE TELLING ME, "I HAD TO
INCREASE MY SALES COSTS BY 30%
TO GET 20% MORE IN SALES AT SUCH
A SMALL AMOUNT OF $1 MILLION."
MM-HMM.
I DON'T SEE
HOW YOU'RE GONNA SCALE
WITHOUT
BUYING YOUR WAY THERE.
GREAT CAUSE...BUT I'M OUT.
Greiner:
I LOVE THE MISSION.
I LOVE THE LOOK -- REALLY CUTE.
BUT I PUT IT ON,
AND I HAD SOME DIFFICULTY
WITH IT BEING COMFORTABLE ON ME
BECAUSE THE RIBBON CAN CUT IN.
DEPENDING ON
WHICH WAY YOU DO IT,
IT CAN CUT INTO YOUR FOOT.
SO, I'M JUST SAYING,
ME PERSONALLY,
I HAD SOME DIFFICULTY
WITH THE RIBBON STYLE.
I'M SURE, FOR A LOT OF WOMEN,
THIS IS COMFORTABLE.
YOU'VE SOLD A LOT.
BUT FOR ME, IT WASN'T.
AND I BELIEVE IN YOUR MISSION,
BUT I DON'T THE PRODUCT,
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
BYE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD LUCK.
Ben: WE DEFINITELY THINK
THE SHARKS MISSED OUT.
THEY MISSED OUT ON A COMPANY
THAT'S CHANGING THINGS,
A COMPANY
THAT'S GONNA GROW,
AND A COMPANY
THAT'S GOING TO BE PROFITABLE,
UM, AND A COMPANY
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE HAD
A LOT OF FUN
BEING A PART OF.
Narrator: IN SEASON 5, JOHN,
SAL, AND ANTHONY MADE A DEAL
WITH LORI GREINER FOR THEIR
PRODUCT, THE PAINT BRUSH COVER.
LORI, WELCOME
TO THE FAMILY.
[ GASPS ] YAY!
AH, CRAP. WHAT?!
SORRY, BARBARA.
THAT IS GREAT.
Narrator: LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
WHEN I MADE MY DEAL, I TOLD THEM
I WORK WITH LIGHTNING SPEED.
THERE IT IS.
[ Chuckling ]
OH! LOOK AT THAT.
AND I KEPT MY PROMISE.
I GOT THEM INTO 2,000 HOME DEPOT
STORES JUST LIKE THAT.
REMEMBER THIS THING?
UH-OH.
I DO REMEMBER
THIS THING.
[ CHUCKLES ]
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
I SAID TO THE GUYS WAS,
"WE'VE GOT TO CHANGE
THE PACKAGING."
WE MADE IT A BOLDER COLOR.
WE CHANGED THE GRAPHICS
COMPLETELY.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT YOUR PACKAGING POPS,
THAT PEOPLE WALK BY, THEY STOP,
AND THEY BUY IT.
NOT ONLY ARE WE
IN HOME DEPOT NATIONWIDE.
WE'RE EVERYWHERE
WE NEED TO BE.
Caputo: LORI'S BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN HELPING US LAND DEALS
WITH ALL
THE MAJOR RETAILERS,
INCLUDING ACE HARDWARE
AND SHERWIN-WILLIAMS.
John:
ALL OUR RETAILERS COMBINED,
WE'RE IN OVER 14,000 STORES
NATIONWIDE.
I THINK WE NEED TO GO TALK
SOME MORE BUSINESS.
SOUNDS GOOD TO ME.
BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
OUR BUSINESS HAD DONE
$35,000 IN SALES.
IN 9 MONTHS,
WE'VE DONE $1.5 MILLION,
WITH ANOTHER $1 MILLION TO COME
IN THE NEXT THREE MONTHS.
CAN I GET ANOTHER
100 PALLETS TODAY?
All: YEAH!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
ALL RIGHT!
Sal: BEFORE "SHARK TANK,"
WE WERE JUST THREE GUYS
WORKING OUT
OF JOHN'S GARAGE.
NOW WE'RE A COMPANY.
WE HAVE 18 EMPLOYEES.
WE HAVE OUR OWN OFFICE,
AND WE HAVE A HUGE WAREHOUSE.
WE'RE NOT JUST
A PAINT BRUSH COVER ANYMORE.
WE'VE NOW INTRODUCED OUR SECOND
PRODUCT, THE ROLLER COVER.
IT'S QUICKLY BECOMING
JUST AS POPULAR
AS THE PAINT BRUSH COVER.
"SHARK TANK"
WAS A LIFE-CHANGING EXPERIENCE,
AND WE'RE LIVING PROOF
THAT THREE GUYS WITH A DREAM
AND AN IDEA COULD GO A LONG WAY.
Together: COVER UP!
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A PRODUCT
THAT COULD TURN A HOBBY
INTO A LUCRATIVE PROSPECT.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MARK PETERSON,
AND I'M FROM
BEAUTIFUL EUGENE, OREGON.
MY COMPANY IS
THE GOLD RUSH NUGGET BUCKET,
AND TODAY I'M SEEKING 60,000
OF YOUR HARD-EARNED DOLLARS
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 15% OF MY COMPANY.
GOLD -- EVERYBODY WANTS IT.
WARS HAVE BEEN FOUGHT FOR IT.
IT LITERALLY MAKES OUR WORLD
GO 'ROUND.
BUT BEST OF ALL,
IT'S EVERYWHERE,
JUST WAITING TO BE FOUND.
AND IT USED TO BE
YOU NEEDED TO SPEND HOURS
WORKING WITH A GOLD PAN
AND PANNING PLAIN OL' DIRT.
"TOO MUCH WORK AND NOT
ENOUGH FUN," IS WHAT I SAID.
SO, SHARKS, I'VE MADE IT EASY
AND FUN FOR EVERYONE,
INCLUDING KIDS, TO FIND GOLD.
INTRODUCING
THE GOLD RUSH NUGGET BUCKET.
NOW, THE NUGGET BUCKET IS NOT
JUST ANOTHER GOLD-PANNING KIT.
THIS KIT CONCENTRATES THE GOLD
INTO THIS SMALL BOWL,
WHICH THEN MAKES THE PANNING
PROCESS SUPER-EASY AND FUN.
ALLOW ME TO DEMONSTRATE.
SIMPLY SCOOP IN
AS MUCH DIRT...AS YOU WANT,
POUR IN AS MUCH WATER
AS YOU WANT...
...AND THEN LET GRAVITY
DO ALL THE WORK.
THE LONGER YOU DO THIS,
THE MORE GOLD WILL CONCENTRATE
IN THIS BOWL.
WHEN FINISHED,
SIMPLY REMOVE THE BOWL,
DUMP THE CONTENTS INTO YOUR PAN,
AND NOW YOU'RE READY
TO PAN SUPER-CONCENTRATED DIRT.
WELL, SHARKS,
WHO WANTS TO DIG INTO
THIS WORLDWIDE OPPORTUNITY AND
STRIKE IT EXTRA-RICH WITH ME?
WELL, HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH THIS IDEA?
I TOOK MY TWO DAUGHTERS DOWN
TO THE RIVER
TO FIND SOME ROCKS
FOR THEIR ROCK POLISHER.
SO, I BOUGHT
A FIVE-GALLON BUCKET
AND A COUPLE SCREENS
AND STACKED THEM ON TOP,
AND THEY PLAYED
FOR AN HOUR OR TWO,
JUST SCOOPING IN DIRT,
POURING IN WATER.
THEY HAD THE BEST TIME.
SO, I KNEW
I WAS ONTO SOMETHING.
O'Leary:
ALL THE EASY PANNING LOCATIONS
WERE JUST DUG OUT
DECADES AGO.
YOU KNOW, UM...
YOU GOT TO WALK WAY UP THE RIVER
IF YOU WANT TO FIND GOLD.
[ CHUCKLES ]
YOU CAN ACTUALLY FIND GOLD
IN THE HOME DEPOT SAND.
DO THEY KNOW ABOUT THIS?
[ LAUGHS ]
[ CHUCKLES ]
IT DOESN'T CONTAIN ENOUGH
TO PAY FOR THE BAG OF SAND,
BUT IT CONTAINS ENOUGH
TO HAVE FUN.
IS IT, LIKE,
GOLD FLAKES OR --
YEAH, UH,
IT'S CALLED MICRON GOLD.
I DO HAVE A SCREEN
THAT WILL SHOW THE GOLD RING
THAT WILL FORM IN THE BOTTOM
OF THE THIS BOWL.
GOLD! GOLD!
SO, THAT GOLD THERE
IS FINE ENOUGH
THAT IT WILL ACTUALLY FLOAT
ON THE SURFACE TENSION OF WATER.
PART OF THE PATENTED PROCESS IS,
IS THAT THE COLUMN OF WATER
COMING OUT OF THE FUNNEL
PENETRATES THE LAYER OF SAND
IT NATURALLY CREATES
AND THEN HITS THE BOTTOM OF
THE BOWL AND THEN SPREADS OUT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SALES?
ARE YOU SELLING THIS ANYWHERE?
ONLINE ONLY, $290,000...
Greiner: WOW.
WOW.
...IN THE FIRST 17 MONTHS.
THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
WHAT DOES IT SELL FOR?
$99.95 PLUS SHIPPING
AND HANDLING.
WHAT'S YOUR PROFIT
ON IT?
ABOUT 70% MARGIN.
WELL, SO, MARK,
THIS ISN'T A TOY.
PEOPLE AREN'T BUYING THIS
FOR THEIR KIDS.
THEY ARE.
50% OF OUR SALES ARE GIFTS.
RIGHT,
'CAUSE YOU'RE KILLING TIME,
YOU'RE GOING
ON VACATION SOMEWHERE...
MM-HMM. YEAH.
...OR YOU LIVE IN THE
MIDDLE OF NOWHERE.
"LET'S GO PAN FOR GOLD."
YEP. EXACTLY.
AND WHAT WERE
YOUR TOTAL --
HOW MUCH MONEY
DID YOU PUT INTO IT?
I PUT $192,000 INTO THIS.
WHOA!
HOW DO YOU SPEND $192,000
ON THIS?
YOU HAD TO BUY
A LOT OF BUCKETS AT WALMART.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YEAH. EXACTLY.
THE MOLDS --
ALMOST $150,000.
WHAT'S UNIQUE
IN THAT BUCKET THAT'S YOURS?
THIS FUNNEL AND THE TWO SCREENS,
THE BOWL, AND THE BASE.
I HAVE TWO PATENTS ISSUED
IN THE UNITED STATES.
I THINK
IT'S A COOL IDEA, RIGHT?
IT REALLY IS ENTERTAINING,
AND IT'S FUN,
BUT IT'S NOT THE GOLD I PAN FOR
ON A DAILY BASIS.
I'M OUT.
MARK, I THINK IT'S CUTE,
BUT I SEE IT AS A HOBBY.
I'M OUT.
I'M SITTING HERE -- "SHOULD
I BUY INTO THIS BUSINESS --
A CLEVER LITTLE GIFT,
IT'S WHOLESOME?"
MM-HMM.
THAT'S WHAT I LIKE.
"OR SHOULD I JUST BUY ONE
FOR MY HUSBAND, BILL?"
CHEAPER.
AND PUT HIM TO WORK.
[ LAUGHTER ]
PUT HIM OUT
IN THE STREAM.
I THINK I'M GONNA BUY ONE
FOR BILL. I'M OUT.
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY ASPIRATIONS
TO PUT THIS INTO RETAIL
AT A DICK'S
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
NO, ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THAT'S
THE BIGGER MARKET, FOR SURE.
BUT HAVE YOU TRIED?
HAVE YOU TALKED TO THEM?
I'VE SUBMITTED IT TO BASS PRO'S.
I HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING.
DO THEY SELL A PANNING KIT
RIGHT NOW?
ABSOLUTELY.
I HAVE A FRIEND WHO DOES THIS
WITH A PUMP.
[ BOTH CHUCKLE ]
AND HE PUTS IT AT THE LAKE BED,
IN THE SANDY STUFF.
AND I-I THINK HE'S NUTS,
BUT EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE,
HE FINDS GOLD,
AND HE SAYS, "GOLD!"
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT ABOUT
SELLING THE GOLD THAT YOU FIND,
IT'S ABOUT FINDING IT.
OH, MY GOD.
YES, IT'S EXCITING.
AND THAT'S --
Greiner:
IT'S THE ADVENTURE.
IT'S THE ADVENTURE,
ABSOLUTELY.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO SAY, I THINK
IT'S ADORABLE AS A KIDS' TOY.
MM-HMM.
I THINK IT'S JUST SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE REALLY FUN.
YEAH.
BUT BECAUSE I SEE THIS
AS A TOY,
NOT REALLY A $99 ITEM
FOR ADULTS...
...I'M OUT.
OKAY.
HANG ON. MARK,
WOULD YOU CONSIDER --
WE CAN'T REALLY SEE
THE FACE OF THAT GOLD PANNER.
WHAT IF KEVIN'S FACE
WAS THERE?
THEN IT WOULDN'T BE A KIDS' TOY
ANY LONGER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Greiner: I LOVE YOU.
THEN IT WOULD BE GREAT
AT HALLOWEEN!
IT WOULD BE.
MARK, THE LONGER YOU STAND
THERE, THE MORE I LIKE YOU.
Greiner: MM-HMM.
AND THE MORE ENTERTAINING
IT IS.
ME TOO.
AND THE MORE I LOVE
YOUR ANSWERS.
O'Leary: WELL,
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT --
I MEAN, I THINK
IT'S SO LUDICROUS
AND SO FRIVOLOUS
AND SO MINDLESS...
THAT HE'LL TAKE --
...THAT IT HAS MERIT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT --
I DON'T KNOW.
Herjavec: HMM.
YOU KNOW, IT'S SO CRAZY.
WHAT'S YOUR OFFER?
IT'S $60,000 FOR 50%,
NO FLEXIBILITY WHATSOEVER.
OH, MAN.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA SELL
A TON OF THESE.
I AGREE.
UNLIKE KEVIN, I'M NOT BLINDED
BY THE GOLD AND THE GREED.
$60,000 FOR 25%.
OH, YOU BETTER SAY YES SO FAST
BEFORE HE SEES ALL THE DIRT.
W-WHAT IS YOUR VISION
FOR MAKING YOU AND I BOTH
A LOT OF MONEY?
YOU'RE JOKING.
Corcoran: NO, HE'S ASKING --
NO, 'CAUSE
HE PROBABLY HAS NO IDEA.
SERIOUSLY?
WHAT, RETAIL? ARE --
ARE YOU THINKING MASS RETAIL
LIKE BIG-BOX STORES?
OH, THAT'S WORK, MAN.
[ LAUGHS ]
HE'S CALLING YOU OUT, ROBERT!
"WHERE ARE YOU?"
"WELL, I'M IN TEXAS NOW."
[ LAUGHTER ]
"I-I'M GOING ACROSS THE STATES.
I'M GOING TO BOB'S.
I'M HOPING
TO SELL TWO BUCKETS."
[ Laughing ] GIVE ME BUCKET
RIGHT NOW! HANG ON.
I'M GONNA GO TO EVERY STORE,
AND SAY...
[ LAUGHTER ]
HERE'S YOUR BUCKET.
ALMOST -- YOU'RE ALMOST --
GIVE ME THE CASH.
[ LAUGHS ]
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
I ACTUALLY THINK
PEOPLE WILL BUY THIS.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A GAG GIFT
WITH A SERIOUS ELEMENT TO IT.
MARK,
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
YOU GOT TWO GREAT OFFERS.
YOU KNOW, ROBERT...
...WE GOT A DEAL.
YOU GOT IT.
[ LAUGHS ]
AWESOME. THANK YOU.
YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
OH, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA SELL
A TON OF THEM.
I THINK WE WILL.
THANKS A LOT, FOLKS.
THANK YOU.
Greiner: CONGRATULATIONS.
Cuban: THANKS, ROBERT.
MARK, YOU'RE DEAD TO ME.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
Cuban: OH, YEAH,
GOLD RUSH NUGGET BUCKET.
Greiner: AWW.
THAT'S A ROYALTY
RIGHT THERE.
[ LAUGHS ]
ROBERT, I WANT 15%.
THAT'S ONE GOOD-LOOKING MINER.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A GARMENT THAT'S FUNCTIONAL
AND FASHIONABLE.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS C.C. CONRAD.
I'M THE FOUNDER
OF BOOBYPACK,
AND I'M SEEKING
AN $80,000 INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE FOR 20%
OF MY COMPANY.
THE BOOBYPACK IS THE FANNY PACK
FOR YOUR RACK.
[ HERJAVEC AND GREINER CHUCKLE ]
IT'S ESSENTIALLY
A FASHIONABLE SPORTS BRA
WITH TWO ZIPPER-ENCLOSED POCKETS
ON EITHER SIDE
THAT HOLD YOUR VALUABLES
LIKE YOUR KEYS, CASH, I.D.,
AND PHONE,
WHILE KEEPING THEM SAFE
AND SECURE.
AND THE POCKETS
ARE WATER-RESISTANT
SO KATIE HERE CAN GO TO
HER FAVORITE MUSICAL FESTIVAL...
[ LAUGHS ]
...DANCE, JUMP UP AND DOWN,
EVEN GET WET...
WITHOUT WORRYING
ABOUT LOSING
OR RUINING HER VALUABLES
IN THE PROCESS.
IT'S THE ULTIMATE
CHEEKY SOLUTION
TO THE "STASH YOUR STUFF"
DILEMMA.
SO, WHICH ONE
OF YOU SHARKS
IS READY TO BECOME
MY BREAST FRIEND?
DO WE WE GET SAMPLES?
YES, WE MADE A CROATIAN FLAG
BOOBYPACK FOR YOU, ROBERT.
OH, THANK YOU.
LORI, YOU'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO GET
ONE OF
THE FIRST TANKINIS,
WHICH ARE HITTING THE MARKET
LATER THIS WEEK.
THANK YOU.
AND, MR. WONDERFUL, YOUR
FAVORITE PHRASE IS ON THERE.
WE HOPE YOU WON'T
USE IT ON US.
WHAT'S
THE FAVORITE PHRASE?
Cuban:
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT.
"YOU'RE DEAD TO ME."
O'Leary: WOW. I LIKE THAT.
I REALLY LIKE THAT.
AND YOU ARE
"THE REAL DEAL"
AND, OF COURSE,
"MAVERICKS FAN FOR LIFE."
THANK YOU. I LOVE IT.
DOES ONE SIZE FIT ALL,
IN CASE A WOMAN HAS --
IS MORE ENDOWED
THAN ANOTHER?
IT COMES SMALL
TO EXTRA LARGE.
C.C., HOW MUCH
DOES IT COST?
$7.17 TO MAKE
THE BOOBYPACK.
AND HOW MUCH
DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
$55.
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
DO YOU MIND TELLING US
WHEN YOU STARTED,
AND THEN TELL US
WHAT YOUR SALES WERE EACH YEAR?
SO, WE STARTED ON KICKSTARTER
IN JANUARY 2013,
AND WE DOUBLED OUR FUNDRAISING
GOAL, AND WE'RE LISTED
AS ONE OF THE MOST-FUNDED
FASHION PROJECTS.
WHAT WAS YOUR GOAL?
OUR GOAL WAS $15,000,
AND WE GOT $32,000 IN 30 DAYS.
IN JUNE OF LAST YEAR,
WE LAUNCHED OUR WEBSITE
AND SOLD $10,000 WORTH
OF PRODUCT THE FIRST DAY AND --
THE FIRST DAY?
THE FIRST DAY.
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE IN SALES
SINCE YOU OFFICIALLY LAUNCHED?
$167,000 IN SALES.
HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
HOW DID YOU MAKE ALL
THOSE SALES? WAS IT ALL ONLINE?
UM, SO, YES,
WE'VE BEEN ALMOST -- PRIM--
LIKE, 99.9% DIRECT
TO E-COMMERCE.
WHAT'S YOUR GAME PLAN?
ARE YOU GONNA STAY ONLINE?
ARE YOU GONNA RETAIL?
SO, SO FAR,
BECAUSE IT'S JUST BEEN ME,
STAYING ONLINE
HAS ALLOWED ME
TO REALLY CONTROL
THE BRAND IDENTITY.
THAT SAID, I'M READY TO TAKE
BOOBYPACK TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
I'M CURIOUS HOW PEOPLE
ARE FINDING YOUR SITE.
WE HAVE DONE, UM,
SOME S.E.O...
GOOD.
...UM, FOR A BRA WITH POCKETS,
RAVE BRA.
DO YOU PROMOTE ON PINTEREST
AND THINGS LIKE THAT?
YES, WE HAVE, OF COURSE.
WE HAVE PINTEREST,
INSTAGRAM, TWITTER.
HOW MANY FOLLOWERS DO YOU HAVE
ON YOUR FACEBOOK?
WE HAVE 11,000,
BUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE GROWING
BY 400 A WEEK.
Cuban:
YEAH, BUT FACEBOOK DOESN'T HAVE
A WHOLE LOT OF RETURN
THESE DAYS, RIGHT,
BECAUSE YOU STILL HAVE TO BUY
TO PROMOTE.
WHAT IS YOUR
CUSTOMER-ACQUISITION COST,
WHERE ARE YOU FINDING
THOSE CUSTOMERS,
AND WHY HAVEN'T YOU HAD
MORE SALES?
WELL, SO, OUR CUSTOMER-
ACQUISITION COST IS $7.17,
AND THEY TYPICALLY SPEND
ABOUT $80 ON THE SITE.
AND THAT'S REALLY
JUST USING FACEBOOK.
AND, YOU KNOW, I SAID
THAT WE'VE DONE SOME S.E.O.,
BUT IT'S BEEN VERY MINIMAL.
WE'RE ABOUT TO RAMP UP S.E.O.
AND START AN AdWords CAMPAIGN.
'CAUSE I WOULD THINK,
IF IT'S $7 TO GET $80
WITH HIGH MARGINS...
MM-HMM.
...JUST SPEND AWAY, RIGHT?
'CAUSE IT REPLENISHES AND --
AND SELF-FINANCES.
WHY -- WHY NOT DO MORE?
RIGHT, I MEAN, WE HAVE REMAINED
CASH-FLOW-POSITIVE
SINCE OUR KICKSTARTER.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE $10,000
IN THE BANK NOW, $7,000 IN --
BUT YOU HAVEN'T PAID YOURSELF
ANYTHING, RIGHT?
HOW --
I HAVE NOT, NO,
FOR TWO YEARS.
HOW DO YOU
SUPPORT YOURSELF, C.C.?
UH, SO,
MY DAD PASSED AWAY
[Voice breaking] BEFORE
MY SOPHOMORE YEAR OF COLLEGE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
SORRY. I SAID IT -- MM.
UM...HE LEFT ME
A BIT OF MONEY,
AND SO I'VE BEEN USING THAT
TO -- TO FUND THIS.
IT WAS MOSTLY INTENDED
FOR GRAD SCHOOL,
BUT HE WAS AN ENTREPRENEUR,
SO I THINK HE'D BE HAPPY
AT HOW I'VE USED IT.
Cuban: C.C., I THINK
YOU'RE STARTING TO REALIZE
WHAT A LOT OF ENTREPRENEURS
RUN INTO.
IT'S A LOT HARDER THAN IT LOOKS
TO GROW A BUSINESS.
AND I CAN TELL
THAT YOU'RE RELENTLESS,
WHICH IS A GOOD THING.
BUT ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
RIGHT NOW --
IT'S STILL MORE PRODUCT
THAN A COMPANY --
FROM WHAT YOU'VE PRESENTED
SO FAR, I DON'T REALLY SEE IT
AS A COMPANY
THAT'S REALLY GONNA SCALE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, I THINK ONE WAY
TO SCALE IS LICENSING.
I KNOW, MR. WONDERFUL,
THAT'S YOUR FORTE.
I LOOK AT THIS WAY -- IT'S
A PRODUCT, NOT A COMPANY YET.
YOU'RE GOING THROUGH
ALL THE CHALLENGES
OF GETTING DISTRIBUTION.
RETAIL IS A VERY VEXING
AND CHALLENGING BUSINESS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
PAY FOR THE INVENTORY,
HAVE TO GUESS
THE FASHION RIGHT,
AND GUESS THE NUMBER
OF EACH SIZE.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
YOU MAY NOT LIKE IT, BUT IT'S
THE ONLY WAY I CAN SEE DOING IT.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $80,000,
ZERO EQUITY.
I DON'T TAKE ANY EQUITY
IN THE COMPANY.
I'M GOING TO GET $10 A UNIT
IN PERPETUITY.
IT'S REALLY A BET ON YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT OFFER.
I APPRECIATE IT.
I KNOW YOU'VE HEARD THIS BEFORE,
BUT I THINK,
AS MY COMPANY IS GROWING,
I DON'T WANT TO SIPHON CASH
AWAY FROM IT.
C.C., I LOVE HOW DECISIVE YOU
ARE. THAT WAS AWESOME.
BEFORE YOU REFUSE IT, C.C.,
YOU SHOULD WAIT TO SEE
IF ANY OTHER SHARK
WILL PLAY BALL
BECAUSE IT MAY BE
YOUR ONLY OPTION,
AND SOMETIMES
THE ONLY OPTION IS A GOOD ONE.
Corcoran:
I'D LIKE TO SPEAK UP.
I THINK YOU'RE A
GREAT ENTREPRENEUR IN EVERY WAY.
YOU'RE THE WHOLE PACKAGE.
THANK YOU.
SO, I'M GOING TO BE OUT
'CAUSE I DON'T THINK
YOU NEED ANY HELP.
OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
C.C., IT'S ALWAYS GREAT.
I LOVE WHEN I SEE SOMEBODY
WITH THE DRIVE TO GO ALL-IN.
AND YOU'RE FOLLOWING
IN YOUR FATHER'S FOOTSTEPS
BEING AN ENTREPRENEUR.
I THINK THAT YOU'RE
ON A GREAT TRAJECTORY
TO KEEP BUILDING IT SLOWLY,
BUT IT'S JUST TOO EARLY
FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
SO, C.C., YOU'VE DONE
A REMARKABLE AMOUNT OF WORK
IN A VERY SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME.
YOU'RE QUICK,
BUT THERE'S ONLY ONE THING
THAT'S BETTER THAN QUICK,
WHICH IS WHAT MARK SAID --
RELENTLESS.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $80,000.
I JUST WANT
A LITTLE MORE EQUITY
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS
A BIT OF A LONGER-TERM PLAY.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $80,000
FOR 30%.
Corcoran:
YOU DON'T NEED HIM.
I'M GONNA MODIFY MY OFFER.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU
THE $80,000 FOR A $10 ROYALTY.
AFTER I RECOUP $320,000,
WHICH IS FOUR TIMES
ON MY CAPITAL,
THAT ROYALTY GOES AWAY.
WHAT REMAINS IS
A 5% EQUITY POSITION.
THE ROYALTY GOES AWAY AFTER
YOU PROVE THIS BUSINESS OUT.
C.C., IT'S NOT --
I'LL HELP YOU DO IT.
I APPRECIATE YOU --
IT -- IT'S NOT
A BAD OFFER.
YEAH.
AND, YOU KNOW,
I'M NOT GONNA SLAM IT OR --
OR SPEAK ILL OF IT.
THAT'S A LOT OF EQUITY.
EXCEPT LET ME TELL YOU...
BUT LET ME JUST --
...YOU'LL PAY AN ACCOUNTANT
$30,000 A YEAR...
BARBARA, CAN I TALK?
FOR GOODNESS' SAKES, BARBARA --
...JUST TO KEEP TRACK OF THAT.
C.C., THE ONLY THING IS...
$30,000 JUST TO KEEP TRACK
OF THOSE DETAILS.
...CAN YOU AFFORD --
YEAH.
CAN YOU AFFORD TO TAKE
THAT MUCH CASH
OUT OF THE BUSINESS
WHEN YOU'RE GROWING?
LET'S SAY YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL
AND YOU SELL THIS BUSINESS
ONE DAY FOR $10 MILLION,
WHICH I THINK
YOU'D LIKE TO DO, RIGHT?
I WOULD LOVE TO DO THAT.
BASICALLY, YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO
HAVE TO PAY ME A FRACTION
OF WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO PAY HIM.
THINK ABOUT IT -- YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO GIVE UP $3 MILLION.
I APPRECIATE YOUR OFFER
AND CHANGING IT,
BUT I DO NOT WANT
TO BE GIVING AWAY MONEY
AS MY BUSINESS IS GROWING.
YOU ARE
GIVING AWAY MONEY.
YOU'RE GIVING 30% OF IT
AWAY FOREVER.
LET HER TALK!
GOOD THINKING, C.C.
WELL, I WOULD LOVE
TO COUNTER YOUR OFFER.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER 25%
FOR $80,000?
NO, I'M GONNA -- I'M -- I'M --
I'M GONNA STICK AT THE 30%.
I'M NOT -- I'M NOT --
I THINK -- I --
I'LL TAKE THAT DEAL --
25% FOR $80,000.
YOU'LL TAKE 25%
FOR $80,000?
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
YES.
YEAH.
Cuban:
WELL DONE, BARB.
THAT'S STRAIGHT OUT
OF MY PLAYBOOK.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
THANK YOU, BARBARA.
WE'LL BE GOOD PARTNERS.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANKS. [ LAUGHS ]
OKAY.
YES.
I SHOULD HAVE
FLASHED THIS AT HER
RIGHT WHEN SHE WAS LEAVING
'CAUSE SHE IS DEAD TO ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, GOD.
SO EXCITED TO START
MY PARTNERSHIP WITH BARBARA.
SHE WAS THE SHARK I WAS
GUNNING FOR FROM THE BEGINNING.
I KNOW SHE'S SO HANDS ON
WITH ALL OF HER DEALS,
AND WE'RE GONNA TAKE BOOBYPACK
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS AN INNOVATION IN THE
GROWING DO-IT-YOURSELF MARKET.
HI, I'M JESSE GENET.
MY COMPANY IS LUMI.
I'M HERE ASKING FOR $250,000 IN
EXCHANGE FOR 5% OF MY COMPANY.
HAVE YOU EVER HAD AN IDEA
FOR A T-SHIRT?
OR MAYBE YOU WANTED
TO PRINT A LOGO
ON ANYTHING OTHER THAN PAPER.
WHAT IF I TOLD YOU THAT,
WITH THE POWER OF THE SUN,
YOU COULD PRINT BEAUTIFUL,
PERMANENT IMAGERY
ON ANY NATURAL MATERIAL?
LET ME SHOW YOU WHY LUMI
IS UNLIKE ANYTHING YOU'VE SEEN.
SIMPLY SNAP AN IMAGE, UPLOAD IT
INTO THE FREE LUMI APP.
THEN PRESS "NEGATIVE," AND IT'LL
TURN YOUR IMAGE INTO A NEGATIVE
THAT YOU CAN SAVE
AND PRINT AT HOME,
OR ORDER FROM US,
AND WE SHIP IT TO YOU.
NOW CHOOSE SOMETHING
TO PRINT ON --
MAYBE AN OLD T-SHIRT
OR A TOTE BAG.
TAKE OUR SUNLIGHT-ACTIVATED
INKODYE,
SNAP THE PACKET,
AND SPREAD IT ON.
NOW TAKE YOUR NEGATIVE...
AND SECURE IT IN PLACE.
JUST 10 MINUTES OUT IN THE SUN
WILL TURN THIS INTO
A BEAUTIFUL, PERMANENT DESIGN.
SO, LET'S SEE
HOW THIS ONE TURNS OUT.
OH, WOW.
SO, THIS IS NOW
A PERMANENT IMAGE.
I JUST NEED TO TAKE THIS, THROW
IT IN THE WASH, AND I'M DONE.
SO, AT LUMI, WE'RE TAKING
PHOTOGRAPHY OUT OF THE DARK ROOM
AND INTO THE SUN.
LUMI CLEARLY HAS
A BRIGHT FUTURE.
WHO WANTS TO JOIN ME?
I HAVE LOTS AND LOTS OF SERVICES
THAT I'VE DONE THIS WITH
THAT PROVIDE CLOTHING
OF EVERY NATURE,
INCLUDING OTHER TCHOTCHKES.
I MEAN --
THE -- THE MASSIVE DIFFERENCE
IS THAT THIS IS D.I.Y.
SO, THERE'S AN INCREDIBLE
MOVEMENT HAPPENING,
AND PEOPLE HAVE AN URGE
TO CREATE THINGS AT HOME.
CAN I SEE
THE ONE YOU MADE?
YES.
DOES ANYBODY ELSE
DO THIS?
NO.
SO, IS THIS PROPRIETARY TO YOU?
DO YOU HAVE A PATENT ON IT?
YES.
THE DYE IS A TRADE SECRET.
A FELLOW IN THE 1950s DEVELOPED
A FORMULA FOR SOMETHING
THAT WAS VERY SIMILAR TO
ESSENTIALLY WHAT I WAS SEEKING.
IT TOOK ME TWO YEARS
TO TRACK DOWN THIS GUY.
WAS HE USING IT AT THAT TIME
FOR HIS OWN BUSINESS?
NO. IT'S DEFUNCT.
AND THEN EVENTUALLY
I CONVINCE HIM THAT IF HE HAS
ANY OLD INVENTORY, THAT I COULD
TAKE IT OVER, BUT IF --
DID YOU BUY IT OUTRIGHT,
OR DOES HE STILL GET A ROYALTY?
HE HAS NOTHING.
I BOUGHT IT OUTRIGHT.
HOW MUCH
DID YOU PAY FOR IT?
[ SIGHS ]
I PAID HIM $50,000.
SO, WHERE
DID YOU GET THAT?
WHERE DID YOU GET THAT?
[ CHUCKLES ]
SO, THAT'S WHEN I TOOK
AN ANGEL INVESTMENT.
HE INVESTED 180K AT 10.5%.
YOU TALKED HIM INTO --
HE GAVE YOU $180,000?
YOU HAD NO SALES?
HE'S INVESTED $180,000...
YES.
...AND HE HAS 10.5% EQUITY
OF YOUR COMPANY?
CORRECT.
O'Leary: OKAY, JESSE.
IN THE LAST --
...TELL US WHAT YOUR SALES ARE
THIS YEAR, PLEASE.
YES, IN THE PAST
12 CONSECUTIVE MONTHS,
WE HAVE $1 MILLION IN SALES.
GOOD FOR YOU.
WOW!
O'Leary:
HOW MUCH DID YOU -- HOW MUCH
DID YOU MAKE OFF THE $1 MILLION?
WE ARE NET-POSITIVE 40K,
BUT WE HAVE BEEN RE-INVESTING
THAT WHOLE TIME.
SO, YOU'RE MAKING $1 MILLION
IN SALES.
WHAT ARE
YOUR COST OF GOODS?
WHEN WE SELL DIRECT
ON E-COMMERCE,
OUR MARGINS ARE 91% BLENDED.
WHEN WE SELL
TO WHOLESALERS, 78%.
WE ALSO HAVE EQUIPMENT.
JESSE, I'M NOT CLEAR
WHAT EXACTLY YOU'RE SELLING.
OKAY.
YEAH, CAN YOU -- DO YOU HAVE
SAMPLES FOR US TO SEE?
YES. I DO.
SO, THIS IS
OUR SHADOW PRINTING KIT.
THIS IS
OUR SUNFOLD PRINTING KIT.
Herjavec: SO, JESSE,
YOU'RE SELLING THESE KITS
FOR DIFFERENT PRODUCTS.
WE'RE SELLING THE KITS.
WE ALSO SELL THE DYE
IN INDIVIDUAL BOTTLES.
OKAY, SO, HOW DO I BUY THAT
FROM YOU -- JUST ONLINE?
YOU CAN BUY IT ONLINE,
YOU CAN BUY IT IN MICHAELS,
YOU CAN BUY IT AT JO-ANN'S.
SO, OUT OF THE --
WHAT DOES IT COST?
WHAT DOES
WHAT KEVIN'S HOLDING COST?
THAT IS $39.99.
$39.99.
Corcoran:
AND WHAT DO YOU PAY FOR THAT?
$6.49.
Herjavec: HOW MANY T-SHIRTS
CAN YOU MAKE?
SO, YOU CAN DO FOUR,
AND THEN YOU CAN BUY REFILLS
AND DO AS MANY AS YOU WANT.
WHAT'S THE REVENUE GONNA BE
NEXT YEAR?
THE REVENUE NEXT YEAR,
CONSERVATIVELY,
WILL BE $2.5 MILLION.
AND WHERE
DO YOU BASE THAT?
WHY -- WHY DO YOU FEEL --
WHY SUCH A BIG JUMP?
WHY DO YOU FEEL YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE THAT KIND OF GROWTH?
BECAUSE
FOR THE PAST FIVE YEARS, UM,
I'VE DEVELOPED A TRACK RECORD
OF AT LEAST DOUBLING OUR SALES.
HOW BIG DO YOU THINK
YOUR COMPANY CAN GET?
LIKE, HOW MANY PEOPLE
WANT TO MAKE
THEIR OWN T-SHIRT AT HOME?
OH, MY GOSH, I THINK
IT'S ABSOLUTELY,
ASTRONOMICALLY MASSIVE.
"ABSOLUTELY,
ASTRONOMICALLY MASSIVE"?
YES! YES! [ LAUGHS ]
OKAY, I WAS JUST --
I'VE -- I'VE SEEN THAT
IN PROJECTIONS BEFORE.
OKAY.
I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE.
I CAN BACK UP
THOSE PROJECTIONS.
OUT OF THAT $28 BILLION
CRAFTING/D.I.Y. SPACE,
ABOUT 18% OF THAT
INVOLVES SOME TYPE OF STAMPING,
MARKING, IMPRESSION --
SO, LET'S -- LET'S -- LET'S
DUMB IT DOWN AND MAKE IT EASY.
YES.
AND I --
YOU'RE CHARISMATIC.
YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF ENERGY.
I LOVE ALL THAT.
NOW REALITY STRIKES,
OKAY?
SURE.
LET'S SAY YOU HAVE
A MILLION-DOLLAR BUSINESS,
WHICH YOU HAVE.
YES.
IF YOU WERE OPTIMIZING IT,
I WOULD ASSUME YOU COULD
MAKE $150,000 PRETAX.
SURE.
THAT'S $100,000
AFTER TAX.
YES.
TODAY, JESSE, YOU'RE ASKING ME
TO VALUE YOU AT $5 MILLION.
YES.
THAT'S 50 TIMES
YOUR FREE CASH FLOW.
YOU SEE ANY PROBLEM
WITH THAT?
LET ME EXPLAIN TO YOU
HOW I ARRIVED AT THE VALUATION.
I JUST ARRIVED AT IT.
IT'S -- IT'S RIDICULOUS.
JESSE,
I-I'M JUST NOT EXCITED
ABOUT THE DO-IT-YOURSELF
BUSINESS.
OKAY.
IT'S JUST NOT A FIT
FOR ME.
OKAY.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
UM, I'M SURE YOU HAVE
A LOVELY BUSINESS HERE.
OBVIOUSLY,
YOU'RE MAKING MONEY.
AND I LOVE YOUR PHOTO KIT,
THE BIG SQUARE ONE...
YES.
...'CAUSE IT'S VISUAL.
YOU GET WHAT IT IS.
THE REST -- IT'S A LITTLE --
IT'S STILL CONFUSING,
AND I'VE BEEN
LISTENING HARD.
YES.
BUT I JUST DON'T
BELIEVE IN IT ENOUGH,
AND I'M A LITTLE UNCERTAIN
ABOUT THE PRODUCT, SO I'M OUT.
OKAY.
OKAY, SO, I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
BA-BAM!
I...I LIKE YOU.
I DON'T LIKE
THE VALUATION, THOUGH.
SURE.
AHA!
I MEAN, IT'S A VERY RICH ASK --
$250,000.
WELL, BEFORE YOU MAKE AN OFFER,
LORI -- WAIT.
BEFORE YOU MAKE AN OFFER,
LET ME MAKE YOU AN OFFER,
AND THEN LORI MAY DECIDE --
HE JUST INTERRUPTED
MY OFFER!
NO, BECAUSE I'M GONNA HELP YOU.
I'M GONNA HELP YOU, OKAY?
YOU MADE
A VERY IMPASSIONED SPEECH.
HOW ARE YOU
GONNA HELP ME?
I'M GONNA -- JUST LISTEN
TO THIS, AND THEN YOU DECIDE
IF YOU WANT TO PARTICIPATE
OR COMPETE, ALL RIGHT?
OKAY.
READY?
O'Leary:
BEFORE YOU MAKE AN OFFER,
JUST LISTEN TO THIS,
AND THEN YOU DECIDE
IF YOU WANT TO PARTICIPATE
OR COMPETE, ALL RIGHT?
OKAY.
READY?
ALL RIGHT, TWO OFFERS --
YOU GET TO CHOOSE
WHICH ONE YOU LIKE.
I'LL OFFER YOU $250,000,
AND HERE'S HOW I VALUED
YOUR COMPANY.
I ASSUMED YOUR $1 MILLION
SHOULD MAKE $100,000 AFTER TAX.
I WOULD PAY
FIVE TIMES THAT MULTIPLE.
OKAY.
SO, IF WE DO IT
THAT WAY...
MM-HMM.
...YOU'RE WORTH
$500,000.
SO, MY $250,000 WOULD BUY
50% OF EQUITY.
BUT IF YOU DON'T LIKE
THAT VALUATION,
I'LL LEND YOU
$250,000, OKAY...
YES.
...AT AN 8.5% RATE...
MM-HMM.
...FOR 36 MONTHS --
3 YEARS --
MM-HMM.
'CAUSE YOU CAN ACTUALLY
PAY IT BACK BY THEN
IF YOUR FORECASTS
ARE CORRECT.
YES.
AND I WANT 12.5% EQUITY
TO DO THAT.
THAT'S A VENTURE-DEBT DEAL.
YOUR COMPANY'S IDEAL FOR THAT.
YEAH.
NOW, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PARTICIPATE IN ONE OF THOSE,
OR ARE YOU STUPID
AND GONNA PAY MORE THAN THAT?
OHH!
LET ME --
FIRST LET ME EXPLAIN
THAT WE'VE ALREADY PROVEN
OURSELVES VERY CREDIT-WORTHY.
WE TOOK -- THE LAST ONE WE TOOK
WAS ACTUALLY A $110,000 LOAN,
WITH INTEREST, AND WE PAID IT
BACK WITHIN FOUR MONTHS.
THAT'S WHY I LIKE THE --
THE DEBT OFFER.
BUT I DIDN'T GIVE HIM
ANY EQUITY. [ LAUGHS ]
JESSE, YOU WANT A LOAN
THAT GETS CONVERTED TO EQUITY,
OR ARE YOU LOOKING
FOR STRAIGHT EQUITY?
I-I WOULD --
I'M DEFINITELY OPEN
TO A LOAN THAT GETS CONVERTED.
[ LAUGHS ]
I HAVE TO SAY, EVEN THOUGH
HE WAS, LIKE, SO RUDE,
THERE IS SOMETHING
A LITTLE APPEALING
ABOUT WHAT HE'S OFFERING,
SAD TO SAY.
WHY NOT GO
HALF AND HALF?
I'M THE ONLY SHARK
THAT'S A PHOTOGRAPHER.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE ARE ARTISTS
LIKE YOU AND I.
I WILL DO HIS DEAL WITH HIM
IF YOU WILL TAKE THAT DEAL.
I WANT TO --
LOOK, YOU GET
THE QUEEN OF QVC,
AND YOU GET A STARVING ARTIST,
HOLD THE "STARVING."
[ LAUGHTER ]
I -- I DO REALLY APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO OFFER.
THE IDEA OF HAVING YOU BOTH ON
BOARD WOULD TRULY BE TREMENDOUS.
DO YOU WANT TO SELL HALF
THE COMPANY FOR $250,000?
'CAUSE YOU'RE ONLY WORTH --
THAT WOULD BE COMPLETELY ABSURD.
I'M SORRY.
WHAT WERE YOU
GONNA COUNTER?
I WOULD SAY...2%,
AND I WOULDN'T EVEN LOOK AT IT
AS AN EXCHANGE FOR THE LOAN.
2%?
I WOULD LOOK AT IT AN EXCHANGE
FOR THE ADVISORY ROLE.
DO IT FOR 5%
SO WE EACH GET 2.5% EACH,
AND I THINK
WE WOULD DO THAT DEAL.
AND IF YOU DO IT
AS AN EQUITY INVESTMENT,
YOU HAVE A DEAL.
[ LAUGHS ]
WELL, THAT'S
WHAT YOU CAME IN ASKING.
I KNOW. [ LAUGHS ]
YOU'RE RIGHT BACK TO --
VERY CLEVER, RIGHT?
YEAH, I-I MEAN,
THAT IS WHAT I ASKED FOR,
AND I DO FEEL IT'S FAIR.
UM, I...I FEEL LIKE
I-I APPRECIATE
YOU GUYS TRYING TO MEET
IN THE MIDDLE ON THAT.
JESSE,
DO YOU WATCH THE SHOW?
I HAVE WATCHED THE SHOW.
OKAY, HAVE YOU EVER SEEN
ANYBODY WALK IN THERE
AND, WHEN ASKED
TO NEGOTIATE A PRICE,
GET A DEAL
BY NOT GIVING?
I'M NOT -- I'M --
I'M NOT IN A MOOD TO NOT GIVE,
I'M JUST TRYING
TO WORK OUT SOMETHING
THAT I THINK
WILL WORK FOR MY COMPANY.
DO YOU WANT
A STRAIGHT EQUITY DEAL?
IF THERE WAS
A FAIR EQUITY DEAL THAT --
A LOAN ADDITIONAL,
I WOULD DEFINITELY ADD LIKE
A 2% KICKER, A 2.5% KICKER.
JESSE, I'LL GIVE YOU
$250,000 FOR 15%.
I SAY NO TO THAT OFFER
BECAUSE IN 2015
AND GOING INTO 2016,
I PLAN TO BLOW THIS UP.
AND I BELIEVE THAT I CAN GO
FOR A MUCH LARGER EQUITY ROUND
AT A LATER DATE.
I GET THAT, BUT --
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A PARTNER...
IT'S --
...YOU HAVE TO BE
A PARTNER, TOO.
I UNDERSTAND.
SO, WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR HERE
REALLY ISN'T THAT MUCH.
SOMETHING -- SOMETHING --
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY --
I WOULD LIKE
TO OFFER UP SOMETHING
THAT I THINK COULD BE
REASONABLE, POTENTIALLY.
BUT -- BUT LET'S MAKE IT --
LET'S  OFFER
SOMETHING REASONABLE.
250 -- 250K AS AN EQUITY
INVESTMENT FOR THAT 5%,
BUT THEN ANOTHER 100K
ON TOP OF THAT
AS A REVOLVING LINE OF CREDIT
FOR ANOTHER 2%, 7%.
THAT'S NUTS!
FOR ANOTHER 2%?
THAT'S NUTS.
JESSE, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO
IS WALK OUT WITH A SHARK.
TWO SHARKS ARE WAY BETTER
THAN ONE SHARK
FOR A WHOLE BUNCH OF REASONS
I THINK YOU UNDERSTAND.
SO, I THINK WHAT YOU SHOULD DO
IS TAKE THIS OFFER.
LORI AND I WILL SPLIT
THE $250,000 LOAN FOR 8.5%.
THAT'S WHAT I SAID
ORIGINALLY, OKAY?
WE WANT 5% EQUITY --
THAT KEEPS US INTERESTED.
YOU SHOULD DO THAT DEAL.
UM [CLEARS THROAT]
THAT'S -- RIGHT.
AM I WILLING TO OFFER --
AM I WILLING TO GIVE 5%
OF THE COMPANY
FOR A $250,000 LOAN
WHEN I, IN ALL HONESTY,
CAN PROBABLY GET A LOAN
ELSEWHERE FOR THAT AMOUNT?
NOT A CHANCE.
I DEFINITELY CAN.
DO YOU THINK A BANK GIVES YOU
THE VALUE OF A SHARK?
ARE YOU KIDDING?
I WOULDN'T GET IT --
NO, I WOULDN'T GO TO A BANK
AT THIS STAGE.
I [CLEARS THROAT]
I WOULD SAY --
I WOULD SAY THAT, AT THIS POINT,
I'M NOT GONNA GIVE UP 5%
OF THE COMPANY FOR A LOAN.
I'M NOT GROVELING.
I'M MR. WONDERFUL,
THE SHARK.
I UNDERSTAND.
I DON'T GROVEL.
I GET WHAT I WANT, ALL RIGHT?
IF I'M NOT GETTING 5%,
I'M OUT.
$250,000, 7%, SAME,
8.5%, 36 MONTHS.
AS A LOAN? I'M --
I'M NOT GONNA TAKE A LOAN
FOR 7% EQUITY IN THE COMPANY.
I'M SORRY.
I'M OUT.
I APPRECIATE THE HELP.
JESSE,
THANK YOU.
JESSE, CONGRATS.
SERIOUSLY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU FAILED.
WAY TO STICK TO YOUR GUNS.
YOU -- YOU ACTUALLY
CAME BACK WITH A --
DIDN'T GET A DEAL.
I'M GOING TO MAKE THIS
INTO A CREDIBLE COMPANY.
GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD JOB, JESSE.
SERIOUSLY.
WHEW! [ EXHALES DEEPLY ]
I DON'T THINK I WAS ABLE
TO GIVE UP ENOUGH OF THE COMPANY
TO INTEREST THE SHARKS,
WHICH I UNDERSTAND,
BUT I DIDN'T WANT
TO LEAVE THE ROOM WITH A LOAN.